In a recent video, we quoted the angry
response of Iranimos, the Archbishop of
Athens and all Greece concerning Egypt's
recent court decision to appropriate the
St. Katherine monastery in Sinai, a
UNESCO protected site. At one point,
Iranimos said, quote, "The Egyptian
government has effectively chosen to
dismantle every notion of justice and
with a single stroke attempt to erase
the very existence of the monastery,
abolishing its religious, spiritual, and
cultural function." erase, that is the
key word here, which this video is
dedicated to. As it happens, past and as
we are witnessing, present, Islam has
always tried to erase the existence and
even memory of those preceding it. those
whose lands it appropriated. As of this
very moment, for example, Muslim
Azarbjan is actively erasing the
Christian heritage of Artzac and other
Armenian lands the Muslim nation
recently appropriated through war and
conquest, specifically by removing
churches and crosses and Christian
cemeteries, as well as spreading false
propaganda, claiming that these lands,
which have been Christian for nearly
2,000 years, Armenia being the first
nation to officially adopt Christianity,
were actually always Turk and even
prototypical Muslim. I've written
extensively about this phenomena. Links
to articles in the description. Now,
here's what's really interesting. The
appropriation and subsequent eraser of
non-Muslim sites preceding Islam has
been so thorough as to rewrite history,
which of course is the whole point. By
altering how the past is understood,
Islam legitimizes itself and more in the
present. From here, we come to the
popular and widespread idea that the
Muslim world was somehow always Muslim.
Consider, for example, the following
words spoken by a young Palestinian
Christian and documented in a 2023
report. Quote, "In view of the economic
hardships and political instability, the
occupation and rising fundamentalism
where we Christians face extreme
difficulties and feel unwelcome, why not
pack our bags and return to Europe?"
Return to Europe. Is this Christian
young man unaware that he is already
living in the very birthplace of
Christianity and that history's earliest
Christians originated from the Middle
East, not Europe? Is he unaware that his
own Christian forefathers were there
centuries before Muslims? How could such
well-known facts escape him of all
people? By way of an answer, here is how
Joseph Hbun, who is also quoted in this
same report, link in the description,
replied to the idea that Christianity is
foreign to the Holy Land. Quote, "This
idea is due to misinformation in the
Palestinian curriculum, which cites that
Palestinian history begins with the Arab
conquest of Palestine without any
indication of the first seven centuries
of Christianity in the Holy Land. The
religious instruction in Palestinian
Christian schools and in local parishes
focuses on faithb building rather than
Christian history in Palestine. This has
led to a lack of awareness among many
Palestinian Christians of the history of
Christianity and the first Christian
communities of the Holy Land in the
first century AD.
Nor is such fake history limited to
Palestinian curriculum. Christian
minorities all throughout the Middle
East have long maintained that the
history taught in public classrooms
suppresses the region's Christian
heritage. while magnifying including by
whitewashing Islams. Thus, during a 2016
conference in Aman, Jordan hosted by the
Jerusalem Center for Political Studies,
Dr. Henna Alani said that quote, "There
is a complete cancellation of Arab
Christian history in the pre-Islamic
era. There are many historical mistakes
and unjustifiable historical leaps in
our Jordanian curriculum. 10th grade
textbooks omit any mention of any
Christian or church history in the
region.
Wherever Christianity is mentioned,
omissions and mischaracterizations
proliferate, including the portrayal of
Christianity as a western, that is
foreign source of colonization,
continued Alcalani. Such revisionism is
not only designed to make indigenous
Christians feel foreign on their own
land. It is designed to make Muslims
view the Christians in their midsts with
suspicion and worse. In the words of
Camil Murit, a retired teacher in Egypt,
quote, "It sounds absurd, but Muslims
more or less know nothing about
Christians, even though they make up a
large part of the population and are in
fact the original Egyptians. Egypt was
Christian for six or seven centuries
before the Muslim invasion around 640.
The sad thing is that for many years,
the history books skipped from
Cleopatra, meaning 30 BC, to the Muslim
conquest of Egypt, meaning 640 AD. The
Christian era was completely gone.
disappeared, an enormous black hole. A
2023 report, links to all of this in the
description, agrees with this
assessment. It says, quote, "The
education program in Egyptian public
schools is devoid of any lesson, text,
or mention of other faiths or religions
with a total emission of Egyptian
Christian or Jewish historical figures
or major non-Muslim religious holidays.
The same goes for Coptic history,
despite the fact that the Coptic Church
played a prominent role. All this
completely agrees with what I recall my
parents, Christians from Egypt, telling
me of their classroom experiences in the
then much more tolerant 1940s and50s
when they were children. There was no
mention of Hellenism, which goes back to
300 BC, 330 BC, Christianity, or the
Coptic Church, 1,000 years of Egypt's
pre-Islamic history. History essentially
began with the indigenous pharaohs
before jumping to the 7th century when
Muslims from Arabia opened Egypt. Yes,
whenever Muslims conquer non-Muslim
territory, Islamic Higography, it
euphemistically refers to the event as
an opening, a fat or futur in plural,
never a conquest. Anyway, according to
Shara Ysef Zara, a politician formerly
involved in the Iraqi Ministry of
Education,
quote, "It's the same situation in Iraq.
There's almost nothing about us
Christians in our history books, and
what there is is totally wrong. There's
nothing about us being here before
Islam. The only Christians mentioned are
from the west. Many Iraqis believe we
moved here from the west, that we are
guests in this country. It's worth
noting that the similar ignorance and
historical revisionism predominates in
the west. Although Christians are in
fact the most indigenous inhabitants of
what is today called the Arab world. I
am often asked by educated people why
Christians choose to go and live in the
Middle East among Muslims if the latter
treat them so badly. At any rate, such
revisionism has not only successfully
indoctrinated Muslims to suspect and
hate Christianity and Christians among
them, which is and are seen as a
non-organic parasitic remnant left by
Western colonialists. But it has even
gotten some indigenous Christians such
as the aforementioned Palestinian youth
who thinks it's time to return to Europe
to believe the same.
This phenomena has also connected to
some bitter ironies. The ancestors of
those Muslims who persecute Middle East
Christians today were themselves often
persecuted Christians who converted to
Islam to end their own suffering. Thus,
Muslim descendants of persecuted
Christians are persecuting their
Christian cousins. Such are the fruits
of the fake history that convinces
modern-day Muslims that their Christian
counterparts are unwelcome leftovers
from the colonial era. In the end, of
course, the Muslim world's
pseudoistorical approach to Christianity
should be familiar. After all, and as
we've seen multiple times, doesn't the
West engage in the same exact
chicainery? In both instances,
Christianity is demonized and its
history distorted by those two unlikely
bedfellows, the so-called left in the
West, Islam in the Middle East. But
while one can understand why Islam
promotes such a fake history, that is to
benefit and elevate itself, the West or
certain elements thereof promotes the
same fake history, but in this case only
to weaken, demoralize and subvert
Western civilization.